depuis 33 ans la langue et la culture
créoles sont célébrées à travers le
monde
un temps fort culturel qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue au collège titans du
port ce matin là c'est un atelier dirigé
par mascarin jardin botanique
départementale pour les classes de 5e
avec ses plantes
il raconte notre histoire
parce que ça c'était le légumineuses
on a découvert les légumineuses à savoir
ce que les gens capital à découvrir leur
culture c'est savoir ce que mal n'a été
fait avant nous ce que tu en penses quoi
de south là histoire de notre
biodiversité métissé cultures traditions
culinaires le créole offre une porte
d'entrée éducatif pour les soixante deux
mille collégiens de l'île ce qui nous a
marqués pardon c'est de voir comment les
enfants ont une peut-être méconnaissance
de ce que au niveau culinaire de ce que
pouvait prendre comme petit déjeuner les
gramounes donc découvrir le somali et le
réchauffé pour eux écoutez c'est pas si
évident que cela de déguster de prendre
plaisir à manger ces mets proposés
pendant cette semaine pendant ce temps
dans cette cuisine centrale les agents
techniques territoriaux des
établissements d'enseignement sont en
action c'est comme nuls 1
les panneaux étaient rares
tous les ans plus de 3 millions de repas
servis pour plus de 35 mille collégiens
en demi pension chaque jour l'éducation
au goût est au centre de leurs
préoccupations au sujet de cette semaine
c'est du goût longtemps à la modernité
c'est à dire on va passer pour les
enfants aussi bien des légumes lontan
puis quand gaye voix mais offre aussi
mais on voit là de laisser une pizza
pizza on la voit la décliner pizza
créole avec saucisses fumées gros
piments et au delà du défi je pense que
tous les enfants même s'ils sont au port
ont le droit de connaître ce que nous
avons connu lire
et puis faire vivre
cette expérience passée pour ça perdure
jusqu'à demain parce que en dehors des
mâts katia boeuf que j'appelle souvent
ce qu'ils sont les hamburgers un bon
petit gars icahn à mon propre
aujourd'hui comme aujourd'hui c'est un
canard avec maïs grain ça peut être très
bon la diversité de ses initiatives de
l'équipe éducative a un vrai rôle
sociétal dans cet environnement urbain
encore plus avec ces nouvelles
générations parfois éloignés des
problématiques de leurs aînés